You know, I was with you on the sins videos
until The Hobbit.
What?
That one was bullsh*t.
So The Hobbit is where you draw the line?
You were fine with all the other videos I
made but The Hobbit was so drastically different
that you can’t stand it?
Dude you completely ignored the book.
Exactly. Are we going to have this conversation
again?
Well, we didn’t even have a conversation
last time. Mostly it was, generally, just
you being a dick. Or, I would say, a f*cktard.
Hey, f*cktard is offensive. The proper term
is “Caucasian American.”
Dude, I mean, “It was in a hole in the ground?”
And you complain about that as a sin? What’s
next? A Tale of Two Cities? “It was the
best of times, it was the worst of times,”
Ding!
Is there some movie version of Tale of Two
Cities that I should be aware of?
Or 1984? It was a bright cold April morning,
and the clocks were striking thirteen.”
What kind of f*cking stupid clock strikes
thirteen? Ding!
I wouldn’t say that.
Why not?
The Shepherd Gate clock outside of the Royal
Observatory in Greenwich strikes thirteen.
It strikes thirteen every day. It’s got
roman numerals zero through 23.
So if you were to go there, I assume you would
confuse 12 o’clock and 7 o’clock?
That again!? How am I supposed to know Final
Fantasy had 14 f*cking games?!
You don’t have to know that! All you need
to know is that if the Roman numeral starts
with “X”, “7” should be the furthest
thing from your mind, and also you should
never see a movie that has that Roman numeral.
I thought Malcon 10 was pretty good. I didn’t
see the first 9 but that one was pretty amazing.
How do you know about the Shepherd Gate clock,
but you don’t know about the first line
of The Hobbit? How is that possible?
I knew the line was from the Hobbit book.
I knew it before I made the video.
Dude the point is not that they used the line
from the book. In movie world, they set it
up as though The Hobbit book that we know
is something that Bilbo wrote to Frodo. Which
is fine. That’s cool. I get that. But then
don’t go pull the first line of the book
that says “It began in a hole in the ground,”
because f*cking Frodo knows it began in a
hole in the ground.
I also knew why the eagles didn’t take them
all the way to Lonely Mountain.
Wasn’t explained in the movie, though.
What?
Personally I think it’s kind of Caucasian-American
of them to not explain it in the movie. As
it is, it just seems like Gandalf can summon
the eagles whenever he needs them, and that
the eagles are just bad at geography.
Said the guy who said, “Idaho is not a real
place.”
I just call it “Southwest Montana,” man.
If the locals want to call it something different,
they’re more than welcome to. That’s their
prerogative.
You might be more of an asshole than Bobby
Brown.
Dude. Alright. Give me a goal. Give me a goal
post.
Do I have to?
Oh, crap. Give me a goal post.
I’m giving you—
(glass breaking)
It’s good!
Give me another goal post.
No.
Come on.
No, I’m not doing it.
It’s no fun to kick without a goal post!
Well, you’re gonna have to get used to disappointment.
I’m gonna kick it anyway.
Don’t kick that thing at me.